huh he blocked me what a [ __ ] loser
I was asked my opinion on this account
I think the content is inappropriate
one of the biggest issues that Tick Tock
has faced is the hypersexualization of
its youngest users
the platforms need to do something
the difference with Tick Tock is that it
encourages you to perform for the camera
and what that means is we're seeing
young users do inappropriate things to
try and get a huge following my daughter
tries to wear bathing suit and that's a
freaking problem
resulted in a Groundswell of older
creators questioning the kind of content
that these kids are putting out there in
the world
she is describing how to quote-unquote
stretcher cap where are your parents
where are your Guardians Society this is
not okay this is nuts via highlighting
what they view is problematic content
and calling not only the creators out
for making it but calling Tick Tock out
for not enforcing its Community
guidelines and banning this type of
content call me a prude call me a Karen
I don't give a sh it's twisted it's sick
and it's wrong
[Music]
a little bit
hey Rosalie how you doing I'm doing good
I'm
good
thanks for having us yeah of course
um everybody's just in the room right
now so I hope you don't mind yeah yeah
no that's cool whatever works so this is
apparently what happened Genie popech is
probably one of the most successful teen
creators on Tech talk hi guys get ready
with me for Halloween her real name is
Rosalie aratola she just turned 16 and
she has almost 7 million followers
she gained a huge following on musically
from the age of 10 carried that
following through to Tech talk and now
she had the ability to expand to an even
wider audience
she's receiving video views from 300 000
to 4.5 million on a daily basis
glad you didn't tidy up for us this is
Rosalie in her natural state I debated
on
it on one of the things with social
media it's like you see the number but
if you were really to like see all these
people in front of you you'd really like
understand how many people the amount of
people that are watching you is
definitely satisfying to see that your
um creation is getting views it's
getting likes it's getting engagement
and comments because you know you were
like it's like somebody making a movie
and they put it out and it gets amazing
reviews and it's forever an iconic movie
same thing with videos and content
creating on Tick Tock and all social
media platforms it's like the likes and
the views and all of that are just the
product like you just see the outcome
like that
presently in the hype house right now
the OG hype house Rosalie and her mother
really wanted her to become famous so
they did everything they could to get
her there stay tuned it's gonna be
amazing we're gonna have amazing content
even at the age of 13 they flew out to
the original hype house where a bunch of
teenage creators film content and try
and grow their followings our new junior
high pulse let's go
they sneaked into the house recorded
videos and of course they went viral
I had a fish here on an automatic feeder
and the fish tank is now next to the
toilet with no fish in it so I'm really
sorry if I unknowingly like invaded your
guys privacies that was never my
intention
she had over a million followers amid
that controversy and that taught her
something it taught her to lean into
that bad girl Persona to post content
that was going to be controversial and
that she'd get rewarded for that
behavior by Tick Tock placing her on its
for you page and putting her out there
on this Global stage to a billion users
so tell me what has been your most
popular outfit that you've worn that
people on tiktok have loved my skins my
skins everybody always loves when I wear
the skims I have a skims onesie it was a
Christmas onesie and I got 3.4 million
likes in that one wow
it fits like a glove
by the age of 15 Rosalie was getting a
number of brand deals back at it with
another empty set of haul with fashion
companies like Xi'an pretty little thing
or fashion Nova they would send her
clothes and they would pay her to wear
those clothes in the posts to try and
get her followers to buy them hi you
guys I just got some clothes from the
wrong way she had become a bona fide
influencer and she was leaning into that
influencer marketing world where you can
make quite a lot of money from Brand
deals on tiktok
the content that does the best for me I
feel like is spontaneous those are
always great or shock value
those are very like interesting because
if you have something crazy going on in
your video it's going to get more
replays more re-watches and that just
makes it Skyrocket
make sure something shocking is
happening that people will just be like
wait wait wait let me take a double take
and want to put their input and opinion
and want to send it to their friends and
one of everybody else to see it
one of the great mysteries of tick tock
is how its algorithm Works how does it
decide what content to promote on the
platform
in a document called algo 101 the
company outlines how its algorithm works
the equation is the company saying the
most valuable content to tick tock is
that which is going to result in
audience engagement and that's the type
of content that Rosalie aratola is
making
she just as a teenage girl dancing on
tick tock but when you dive into her
account it's caused many people to ask
is this what kids should be doing online
now
it's Insanity to me that this is like a
normalized thing that we're taking 12 13
14 year olds dressing them into almost
nothing and making them famous nobody
seems to battle can I
people just when they realize my age
they're like in this like shock or
disbelief that I'm so young and they're
like why are you posting things like
that why are you dancing on Tick Tock
while you're dancing in crop tops why
are you doing this why are you doing
that just why are you doing you as 16
and the funny thing is because like you
could go to a school
a public school and you'd probably find
a million other 16 year olds just like
me that are wearing the same clothing as
me that are doing their makeup just like
me everything just like I am I'm doing
what every other 16 year old girl is
doing I'm just being viewed by a lot of
people and people think that they're
that's dangerous I guess
why should I not be doing something that
is so kid-friendly and so like normal to
teenagers because the weirdo in the
corner is watching me with provocative
thoughts why should we leave they should
be the ones you know filtered out hey
girlie so I wanted to give you guys a
follow-up video on Jenny poppik it's
about three months since I last talked
about her and her original Tick Tock
page was banned for a second time
[Music]
the most severe action that Tick Tock
can take against a Creator is to
deactivate an account
we've seen Rosalie aratola's account
deactivated twice and reactivated twice
this is just kind of goes to show how
much of a problem child she is for tick
tock
when it comes to the issue of
hypersexuality of miners on the app Tick
Tock takes the view that it cannot look
at this content through the prism of the
predatory male gaze it wants to see the
video through the perspective of the
Creator who made it and what that means
is that Tick Tock has an if in doubt
leave it up Mantra this has really
helped Rosalie aratola because it means
that content she's made that some may
say is inappropriate that's allowed to
stay up because she has so many
followers and she's created such a name
for herself on the app
so why do you think you were lucky
enough to get your account back I mean I
have like 6.7 million so it's like how
can you just like deactivate somebody's
account like that that has like worked
so hard
to uh and dedicated like a lot of their
time to your app and also I think that
since it happened once before they're
like oh well she's been banned once
before like it wasn't a big deal the
first time this is just like a
misconception again misunderstanding
let's restore it again
I think one of the biggest questions for
people who follow accounts like the
genie popech account is where are the
parents do the parents allow her to
behave this way are they watching what
she's posting the answer is yes her
parents are often seen in her videos
with her and that has resulted in even
more questions
her father George aratola sometimes
appears in her posts he can be seen
picking her up and carrying her out of
the frame
do you find it strange that seven
million people follow Rosalie yeah I do
for a certain extent yeah I do I could I
could understand how I can see a lot of
children maybe her age and even younger
who who want to Aspire to do the same
things
it's just a whole new world I didn't
grow up like that or our social media
was uh lunchtime but uh yeah you know I
just uh gotta take care of my baby girl
why do you think she's become so
successful so quickly
because she wants it yeah she wants it
you know she's been manifesting it it
was like in the stars for her or
something you know
I'm literally a normal 15 year old girl
just going through life on social media
on the internet I guess some people like
to speculate things when your parents
are involved and this must be a play to
get money they must be exploiting you
when in reality I just have two loving
and caring parents who support the
career path I want to take with my life
to become an influencer is one of the
most sought after professions for kids
these days they want to reach that level
of Fame online they see influences with
millions of followers and want that
lifestyle
what this has resulted in is Ted talk or
teenagers on Tick Tock devoting huge
amounts of time to build their following
and make high quality posts that are
going to hit that for you page has kind
of become an industry in and of itself
the global influencer market was valued
at 13.8 billion dollars in 2021. this is
huge money
teenage Tick Tock is Big Business
did you finish stranger things uh yeah
you did
like look
Who the hell's dad dress like that
[Music]
oh that's like a remix huh they sped it
up they're so pretty oh Superstar
since I worked so hard for my money on
tick tock
what do you want to do with it
here's me
I kind of just want to save it and I
guess get a cheap car and maybe do that
stock thing because could I lose money
with the star thing I don't see Amazon
going lower than what it is now it's
just gonna go back up everybody
everybody shops on Amazon what I'm
saying is I don't think you should be
spending like fifteen twenty thousand
dollars on a car I want to go buy a
carbo rarely show that way it sits in
front of the house because you don't
even have a driver's license
but I'll say after that
shotgun I'm coming with you
shotgun shotgun with the shotgun
oh my gosh
[Music]
there are a lot of safety concerns with
having kids you know as young as 10 11
12 13 all the way to 15 having millions
of people following them online
we've seen cases where there has
actually been a real physical danger or
risk
not only does it open them up to
potential stalking issues or receiving
adult x-rated content from people they
don't know it also creates a world where
their content is being viewed as child
sexual abuse material
it's stressful at times not only do I
worry about her just being my little
girl now I worry about her being my
little girl who's on a platform where
there's millions of people who are
watching her
but if if what she does can help her be
a better person can make her money that
because she could put herself through
college or better herself as a as an
adult in the future then I don't see a a
parent who who wouldn't want that for
their child or who wouldn't try to
support it and protect them as much as
they could
not Tick Tock we want to create an
environment where positivity and
creativity can Thrive the team that has
to handle minor safety issues inside
Tech talk is called trust and safety we
use a combination of innovative
technology and thousands of safety
experts based around the world it has
about 40 000 human moderators around the
world that are viewing Tick-Tock content
and deciding on a daily basis what to
take down and what can stay up now for a
quick tour of our guidelines our
commitment to the community starts with
our policies what the trust and safety
team does is it writes policies to try
and ensure that danger is reduced on the
app and that the children who use the
app are safe we expect everyone to
adhere to this code of conduct and the
guidelines it says miners cannot be seen
to be undressing cannot be seen to be
dancing in a sexualized way but a lot of
creators feel as though they see a lot
of teenagers doing exactly that
for those who don't know that's Jenny
papak every single one of her videos
violate tick tock's adult nudity and
sexual activity guidelines this is like
just disgusting children should not be
allowed to do stuff like this on this
platform
look
the genie popech account has caught the
eye of a number of Watchdog creators or
Vigilantes who highlight child
exploitation if it was nicest would when
she was 15. that Predator would have his
whole existence always off the face of
the Earth
they are using
of
problematic the influencer world has
become no kid should be doing the type
of stuff this little one is doing
that teenagers parents and children are
doing things online that maybe they
shouldn't or that maybe one day they'll
grow to regret
when you share your children on these
public platforms you are allowing the
worst of society access to your child's
image and video and information and
that's scary so safety is a big concern
but also the element of privacy it is an
invasion of children's privacy to be
exposing their daily life and their
daily existence as content and as
entertainment for strangers on the
internet
better because the way some parents
Sarah Adams is a stay-at-home mum based
in Vancouver she runs a tick tock
account called mum Uncharted and she
regularly highlights content that she
describes as child exploitation her
entire account is about calling Tick
Tock out for allowing this kind of
content on the app
[Music]
little girls
she started looking at Jenny's posts and
I think initially she just thought that
this was just another teenage girl but
the more she watched she realized this
is actually quite problematic and there
was one Post in particular that she took
issue with
I was reaching out to my community to
ask am I missing something have we
skipped forward from 13 to 21 this feels
very new and uncomfortable for me am I
alone in this so yesterday I posted a
video from this creator
and it got this
I got reported for
minor safety
one thing I don't want is
it ever to be an attack and I can
understand
how it is exciting
and validating to receive all of this
attention online but just to let them
know that they are so much more than
that sexualized
Creator they are on these platforms and
they are more than their body
we're gonna do the Ruby's Hair
we haven't done a video like this
when Sarah first started using Tech talk
she was really targeting The Mummy run
accounts that's accounts where parents
are posting the daily lives of their
kids and Sarah believes that that is
actually akin to child exploitation
little girls make big news in Long Beach
California they're having a beauty
parade 100 of them between the ages of
four and six competing for the title
Miss California Junior the idea of
pageant mums or Dance Moms has existed
for decades we've seen parents push
their kids in these ways for a really
long time she's got a lot she is tops of
all the Tiny Tots the difference with
social media is that it's Amplified the
ability to do that now you can do it
from the luxury of your own home
wherever you're based and that Allure Of
Fame is leading a lot of parents to post
content about their kids online to try
and grow these followings at no point is
it appropriate to film your 13 year old
daughter in a bathing suit having an
outdoor shower in slow mo and post it
publicly on the internet what are these
garbage parents thinking I have realized
that there are a lot of parents who
aren't protecting their own children
online so if parents are going to
protect their own children Society
individuals like myself and creators I
work alongside have to step up and say
enough is enough and hopefully our
voices get so loud that these companies
hear us and the brands who are
supporting this content hear us and the
other adults who are consuming the
content think long and hard about what
they are consuming and maybe hit that
unfollow button hi everyone this is
Steve Steve is here to validate my point
that the majority of men who are in my
comments calling me a Karen and telling
me to mind my own business because I
brought up minor safety on this app are
indeed the ones
following miners on this app they don't
want their content to go away so thanks
for proving my point Steve you are gross
I honestly don't know
how these platforms are managing on the
back end because if what I am seeing on
my side is worrisome
and that's getting through the cracks
what isn't making it on there
that's the one I was telling you about
it's hard to tell how old she is
yeah because there are no longer 13 to
18 year olds they are gone
all of them look 18 plus
when talking to trust and safety
insiders at tiktok
content moderation is defined as an
impossible task
if we just look at the first three
months of this year
Tick Tock removed over a hundred million
videos but that's only one percent of
the content that was uploaded in that
same period
10 billion videos were uploaded in that
same three months they're continuously
struggling with dialing up content
moderation and dialing it back down
if they turn it up as high as it can go
they're accused of over censoring if
they dial it all the way back and allow
anything on the app they're accused of
not protecting children
would you wear this one
try it on and then I wanted you to wear
like I have like an army dress
yeah but I don't know if you want for
your Tick Tock or mine yours hi yeah
yeah yes yes yours yeah yeah please
Rosalie's mum Maria is the true
Mastermind behind the genie popech
account she's encouraged Rosalie to
create this online Persona she
encourages her to lean into shock value
content
and sometimes Maria is actually in the
videos alongside Jenny dancing just as
suggestively as her daughter my mom is
the girl she's my mom my best friend my
sister everything my partner in this and
so she basically gives me my ideas if I
don't have any she'll give me a type of
video to make sure
sometimes she even buys my outfit and
she's the one that takes me to film it's
most of my videos
most of my videos that I've done with my
mother are my most shocking videos
foreign
I always knew that I'd be
famous one day
I didn't know when but I just knew and
so I was I was I've aspired to be that
my whole life mommy
we love the attention I've always loved
that I think I'd take Fame over money
any day
my mother
Jenny's Niche on Tick Tock would be
basically just dancing
and doing the dancing Trends but then
like that gets a little boring after a
while because nobody wants to just
continuously see this episode we have to
switch it up at times so we post videos
on Tick Tock that contain shock value to
attract viewers and to attract attention
but as far as being inappropriate I mean
there has to be some sort of shock value
to a video in order for it to go viral
to a certain extent so we know what
we're doing I think people think take
things the wrong way you know what I
mean but do I think her videos are
inappropriate maybe a couple of them
might have been inappropriate
but as far as her whole content no
of course a lot of risque content that
would get somebody my age 20 years old
banned from the [ __ ] app but no when
kids do it when kids do it it's
completely okay
one of the ways to become really
successful on Tech talk is to post
content so controversial that it's going
to result in people criticizing you or
attacking you or calling out your posts
and that actually ends up boosting them
this girl is a hundred percent being
exploitable Mom and it's the most
disgusting thing you've ever seen what's
so cringy about Jenny Papa when other
creators have criticized Rosalie aratola
for her content her mother Maria is very
defensive of her daughter and she comes
after these creators to try and shut
them down
have your address
it will literally go to your house
okay you don't think I will I will go to
your house
I'm not a troublemaker I don't make
trouble but when you bring it to me you
know I'm gonna that's it when you talk
about my daughter it's like you're
talking about me like whatever you say
about her is affecting me ten times
worse and I know people have to create
drama and say things that are not true
in order to get those views but come on
at my expense at my daughter's expense
I'm tired of it I'm tired of it why
can't it just be positive
how many more of these cases will it
take for it to finally come to an end
the fact that so many children are being
exploited for fame and money by their
own family by their own parents when is
it ever going to end I think that she's
just seeing what everybody else sees on
social media and like the whole help
thing I've explained to many people I
was never asking for help it's
ridiculous she only made videos
because she just saw the other guy's
video yeah everybody's jumping on to
make videos so I can get views yeah to
jump on the trend of making a video
about Jenny papage because that's what
everybody else is doing right now but
exploiting exploiting here's another one
and who is this all these moms I said
that about the moms the stupid idiot
moms 40 50 year old mothers mad mad why
because why because they're husbands are
perverts it's right you're probably
watching you
and probably it's not it's not it's not
our fault
what's wrong with this family what is
wrong with this family why are they rich
and poor at the same time Family getting
along equals everyone confused
something's off you can tell she was
forced to do that last part are they
abusing you are you okay I feel like
it's a trafficking situation
a traffic what I'm literally standing in
the living room doing a tick dog yeah
I'll be over this in like an hour
there's been there's been times where
she she doesn't want to do a video and
I'll be like well I have this great idea
and I don't and I don't want it to be a
waste so she'll do the video and then of
course since she didn't want to do the
video it you could tell in the video she
didn't want to do it so they may take
that one video and be like oh well her
mom made her do that and then it's a
domino effect but it's not an
exploitation and it just kills me inside
to think that people think that of me
[Music]
so I'm down the rabbit hole of these
mummy ran accounts again so we've seen a
increasing number of creators
highlighting the Dark Side of influencer
culture
highlighting the problems of having
children online
but what we don't know is what the
long-term impacts of that is going to be
and this is going to be a problem that
Tick Tock is going to have to face in
coming years this issue isn't going to
go away it's only going to get worse and
I don't envy Tech talks trust and safety
team they are stuck in the middle of
this tug of war
have you found any particular accounts
that you find really concerning that
have been shut down
the ones that have been shut down always
come back
always come back I haven't seen any
extremely large accounts be banned and
stay band
why do you think that is
I think accounts of that magnitude and
popularity make the app money
it's good for the app shock value
controversy trending topics you know
single account on Tick Tock is making
national news
that's good for the platform
what about for the kids
[Music]
it's going to be tough on the kids yeah
girls that are my age 15 16 maybe even
14. I hope that they can just look at my
videos and feel like they can be like
that too without feeling bad about it
because a lot of people
put you know negativity on the way I am
and I hope that they see me ignoring
that and me still doing me and ignoring
the negativity and and are like well if
she doesn't care and if she's okay then
maybe I can and are just influenced by
that a role model
[Music]
everyone it's my birthday
foreign